oscar inoa who gets the start for the
braves in the opener of this four-game
set you know oh and 0 on the year with a
5-3-0 era last time out through the ball
really well against the orioles four
innings two hits five strikeouts works
out of the stretch here's the pitch
and a breaking ball and it's banged into
left field and a base hit for martay
that'll bring jesus aguilar to the plate
with a man on inoa checks back looks at
the runner now delivers and the ball is
ripped through the right side an
opposite field 0-2 hit driving in the
run and it's one-to-nothing marlins the
marlins have runners at first and second
with one out and brian anderson comes to
the plate here's a ground ball base hit
through the left side aguilar being
waved around here he comes and he will
score brian anderson adds another ribby
to the tally and it's two-nothing miami
marlins are at first and second and
garrett cooper d-h
garrett cooper left center field base
hit that is going to bring home matt
joyce and give the marlins a
three-nothing first-inning lead so not
the kind of strike the braves had hoped
for tonight and they will face young
left-hander trevor rogers who was the
13th overall pick in the draft fellows
back in 2017. making his fifth start on
the year 21 innings 6 e.r.a a lot of
that came in one bad game and they're at
the corners with one out so here's darno
travis had a great road trip hit 4-10
and the one-two
is chopped slowly toward third that's
tough play anderson can't make it
everybody's safe a run is in it's a 3-1
game first and third two outs now for
the brave second baseman this runner
goes ground ball up the middle bernie
can't knock it down a run is here
albee's comes through with a two-out hit
and the braves are down one
is down the right field line it's a base
hit game tied here comes ozzy around
second on his way to third joyce digs it
out of the corner he won't stop ozzie
he's gonna score standing up and the
braves have come back in the bottom of
the first with four
so a lead off double brings up pecunia
and he launches one down the left-field
line that's a fair ball that's headed
for the corner it'll be a ground rule
double
dansby will come home and score atlanta
extends the lead it's now five to three
part of the order aguilar an rbi
stingless first time this one on the
ground riley nice play
long throw freddie offline and could not
apply the tag aguilar broke toward
second and got tagged out heads-up play
by freddie freeman not to quit on the
play a swipe tag missed aguilar stumbled
at the bag and freddie tagged him out
what a great play is her game behind
miami broken bat roller toward third
let's see if riley can make a good throw
this time he did
and that will retire the side three up
three down for inoa who's on a roll it's
5-3 braves five runs on eight hits two
on nobody out one two swing and a miss
he took something off first out here in
the third after back-to-back singles 3-2
swinging a miss a fastball away flowers
down on strikes so back-to-back caves
for trevor rogers rogers coming in
tonight with 29 strikeouts and 21 big
league innings now on 2-2 swats in a
swing and a miss a fastball down and
away rogers got him he strikes out three
in a row after back-to-back hits
garrett cooper will lead off for the
fish
this one is popped into shallow center
acuna streaking diving and he makes the
play
what a grab by acuna to rob cooper
yeah tip your camp ronald that was a
great catch no i think he's i think he's
busting marcel for not getting the ball
terrific play by ronald acuna jr top of
the order for the braves third time
through against trevor rogers another
2-2-2 acuna junior gets him with the
fastball the one-two
struck him out five in a row he has
fanned as freddie takes a seat
and he's swinging a miss wow how about
that six straight strikeouts he looks
like a man
garrett cooper the dh he's one out of
two
took a little off dropped it in there
for a strike cooper didn't like it he
turns and heads back to the dugout and
stares
at mark wegner first strikeout for o'day
and the marlins have the tying runners
on they have alfaro coming up
little tapper back to the mound catcher
running good throw gets him and he did
and that will retire the side no runs no
hits two left bottom six atlanta
protects a two run lead
as chris martin comes on to work the
seventh and the top of the miami order
he protects a 5-3 atlanta lead and the
marlins will again bring the tying run
to the plate and he came back to get him
aguilar strikes out
chance for free rbi he couldn't make
contact big pitch by martin two out is a
swing and a miss 16 straight scoreless
innings for chris martin he works around
a lead off double so alfaro two on two
out key spot in the game ball and two
strikes to al farro and he hits one
through the left side to base it they're
gonna wave rojas around third he's
coming home and the marlins are back
we're gonna run harlan's have the tying
run on not going the pitch is chopped
over the mound
backpedaling is melance in one play the
throw to first harrison's going to try
to go to third he's going to be tagged
down what a great heads-up play by
swansea to get back to the bag harrison
tried to go first to third on a chopper
and he's thrown out for the second out
of the inning unbelievable melanson
needs one more to preserve a one-run
atlanta win
fly ball well hit acuna broke in now
drifts back turns and makes the grabs
shy of the wall and the braves have won
game one what a game